[birds chirping]
You are Mari the housekeeper.
He's told me of you.
[thud]
Some creatures must go
back to go wild, it seems.
Monsieur Trepagny smashes
them with his stick at night
and they know to stay
away from our bed.
He does have
dominion over all.
As his wife, I will therefore
need you to serve my needs.
Help me see to the house so
that I may improve the estate
and have it well on
the way to prospering
so that our children may in turn
enjoy the bounty of this land.
You will bear no children.
MELISSANDE: I am the
lady of the house.
I steer the man.
In time, I will steer
him any way I want.
To renovate, toss out old habits
back into the forest where
they belong.
There is my dear husband.
CLAUDE: I was out
searching for Sel
and I found something, Mari.
These seem to have run
away from my sanctum.
What do you know about this?
Nothing.
And Monsieur Sel?
He took has departed.
I go away for one day and
my doma falls to disorder.
You saw nothing at all?
As the housekeeper, you
should be aware of the comings
and goings on the estate.
A dog could do better.
[smash]
Perhaps you can discover what
has happened to Monsieur Sel.
I will speak alone
with Melissande.
[tense music]
Go on.
[door slamming]
I see now the arrangement who
wish to design for yourself.
I have made no such
designs, my cherie.
I wish to do only beautiful
things in this doma
and you will be my partner
in this, and as my partner,
you will learn to look
past my many flaws,
and I will look past
your shortcomings,
which I'm sure are few.
[exhales]
Did you know that I
sailed across an ocean
and walked into
the endless forest
that I could find
the correct man
to bestow my maiden head on?
That is no small thing.
There are deeper bindings
towards which we must work.
The binding of the
two into a one.
There will be no more
binding nor any more bedding
until you tell me the truth.
I gave it once.
I may never give it again.
Which truth this?
There are so many
floating about.
Pluck one for me
and I will tell it.
Mari.
Yes.
MELISSANDE: You
have lain with her.
What would you have me do?
You have given her a son.
Did she tell you that?
MELISSANDE: Nobody
told me a thing.
I have eyes-- a brain.
They will know when you've
gone to visit her cabin
and when you have not.
We will have a proper
wedding ceremony.
I will wear a special dress.
There will be dancing.
Yes, of course.
We will have a
wonderful ceremony.
Now I am brimming with ideas
on how to improve the doma.
You spoke true of its
beauty, but it must be tamed.
Not everything will lay
down for you, Melissande.
This is my doma.
And as its master, I must stride
it with vigor and authority.
You may stride anywhere
you like with as much vigor
as you may muster.
But your visit Mari's
cabin at your own peril.